welcome to episode 136 of film courage
we are thrilled to have you join us this
fall Sunday my name is Karen Gordon and
I'm David Brannon our guest today is
nick lewis Nick makes his producing and
direct or 'i'll debut with rise and
shine the Jay DeMerit story a California
native Nick studied at the University of
California Santa Barbara and currently
lives in La Jolla California he balances
his time between being a successful
practicing attorney and his producing of
the film rise and shine the Jay DeMerit
story Nick also wrote the film with his
partner ranko 22 lugia hope I said that
I got who's an acupuncture amazing yeah
if you guys would see how he spells this
last name and I would love to have you
try to pronounce that said one more time
cared toodaloo gia oh it's amazing it's
amazing with no prior filmmaking
experience Nick Renko and
cinematographer zack salesman embarked
on a year-and-a-half journey covering
three continents following soccer player
Jay DeMerit from his Green Bay roots all
the way to the 2010 world cup rise and
shine became the highest crowdfunded
independent documentary film on
kickstarter raising over two hundred
twenty-three thousand dollars with a
total of 1937 passionate and committed
backers the film is going to be released
nationwide this Thursday November third
2011 and over a hundred theaters you can
you can purchase advance tickets right
now at Jay DeMerit story calm rise and
shine the Jay DeMerit story is a true
account of a young Americans impossible
journey a journey never experienced or
heard of in the soccer world after
college Jays demerits dream of playing
pro soccer in Europe it seemed
unreachable sleeping in an attic
painting houses and eating beans and
toast to survive Jay took the most
unlikely route to the top I'm wondering
how many people listening have eaten
being the combination of beans and toast
is that home plate protein might be
after not making the professional
leagues in the u.s. Jay left for Europe
at the age of 21 without any
professional experience carrying only a
passport $1,500 in a backpack the film
documents Jays journey from the bottom
playing in sunday partly in lower level
division London clubs earning 40 pounds
a week to playing in the English Premier
League to starting in the 2010 world cup
I am just pumped for today's episode of
film Kuragin you guys listen you're
really going to want to you're going to
want to watch this trailer online to
feel the impact from this on incredible
story as we mentioned this movies
playing all over the country this
November third you can go to Jay DeMerit
story calm and see if there's a theater
near you this one is receiving press
from all the major outlets from the LA
Times to variety to indieWIRE to the
Washington Post Sports Illustrated
Huffington Post it just goes on and on
and on yeah please welcome to film
courage via telephone mr. nick lewis
hello welcome Nick hey thank you so much
grab me guys and happy Halloween weekend
everyone out there absolute Nick we have
a lot of ground to cover there's so many
aspect of this story and then of what
you've done as a filmmaker and what Jay
DeMerit has done that you know it just
gives you goosebumps now your fellow
co-writer and co-director Renko has also
an equally compelling story as Jay
DeMerit so since the movie begins with
their friendship and it's an amazing
story can you tell us about the
friendship between Jay and Renko and
rank owes dream to play soccer and how
his life turned away from the sport that
he loved so much yeah definitely I mean
there's so much to the film and Jade
story and the stories that have really
come out a Jay story and that's
obviously one of the big ones um I met
Jay when he was just another guy in
college simple as that and he was
playing soccer with Rocco and Miss
Chicago um just that you know playing in
college soccer at a school that wasn't
really but well-known great soccer
scoring
like that but they achieved some success
and Rocco and Jay were really good
friends Rob back sequin got their kind
of stayed on his couch for the first few
months um ronco God something that's
called exercise I'm probably not that
they're right but essentially the
overworked his body and it affected his
kidney and it's already started to break
down and this was after college and he
couldn't find a solution he went to
doctors over and over and you couldn't
get either diagnosis or something that
would make it better so he actually went
to Asia to China to seek out on ancient
medicine ancient oriental medicine and
through that he was treated and this was
after you know suffering for a while for
years actually and he and Jay lost touch
Intel and I don't want to put the aux
before the horse because a lot I guess
at this point the listeners heard is you
know Jade the college soccer player but
he went on and Jay had his own journey
and for now I'll just say that their
their paths crossed again at a later
time when Jai was actually playing
representing his country I'm playing a
game in Los Angeles and the net up and
at that point Morocco is still very sick
and essentially Jay I'm said look if you
need to kidney here and just let me know
it what it world what I need to do um lo
and behold you know years later now we
have a film coming out about Jay and
speaking of this film you know going
back to the beginning as you're
mentioning there Nick it was your idea
to take Jay story and to make a movie I
mean was it simply something that you
thought would be cool or was it
something that you you really felt had
to be done I mean was this an idea that
you just
get out of out of your head once it once
it kind of struck to you yeah we had a
title originally was when we kind of
wrote up you know put a script together
and what the documenter is going to be
in the title of the story that needs to
be told so that kind of answered that
question we really thought it was just
something that needs to be told because
for one Jay was um getting ready to play
in the world cup in south after the last
summer and it was actually I don't
around will too much but you know there
was an article written by journalists in
South Korea and set out all the players
at the World Cup Jays path there was the
most unlikely and then that covers so
many stories about so many people
getting to the World Cup um and it
really was just something we felt needed
to be told because of the way that he
had no gotten to the World Cup I mean
it's a once-in-a-lifetime story I think
were you part of the discussion of
pitching the movie idea to J and if so
did you think that he would say yes yeah
Bronco talk to him first and then we
both got on the phone with him and you
know as you guys said we are not
full-time filmmakers so it was it wasn't
like we had you know master plan we just
said hey Jay would like to document your
story originally we actually um were
just going to kind of oversee it and we
had a director who the professional
director and a family friend of mine
actually who had worked in in various on
soccer related stuff like filming in
England for various you know companies
and it was all that was a plan but about
a week before shooting again he had the
family issues and pulled out he just
couldn't do it he couldn't be the
traveling on so we were really left with
a choice at that point and we had found
a great cinematographer um you guys
mentioned his name of Jack Saltzman and
we talked to him and he said yeah I was
gonna say you got the hard name right
and the haha just messed it up there are
cute in you can hit continue he said we
could do it you know he said look you
guys know this
and we definitely uh no the game of
soccer were look very passionate and so
she said we could do it we didn't know
if we could do it but we just jumped
right into it because we didn't have any
time I mean it was a that was why we
want to do a documentary that actually
been talk of doing a feature but we
wanted the document the present I mean
you know to have the opportunity to get
to capture Jay at the world cup from you
know on the field who actually behind
the scenes and off the field or even
gave him his own personal camera so you
get to see kind of threw his eyes what
he was experiencing and then she was
also on the way out of England so it was
really just a a moment where we didn't
have time to think about it we just
there's happy go you make I'd like to
stay with the moment of you pitching Jay
you know like how did he respond me was
he on board from from the very beginning
was he reluctant he was a little
reluctant I think for a few reasons one
is because um he is a pretty humble guy
and I think the reason he's humbled
because of where he came from you know
he wasn't some limit came up in the
quote unquote system so he's really been
able to I think out of the perspective
where he feels blessed to be where he is
so he didn't want to be the guy that has
you know look at me here's a movie about
me but um as it went on you realized
that it really isn't about him it's
about the journey and it's about
inspiring other people but back back to
specifically your question is you know
you entertained it and I guess he had
some reservations but at same time I
think you realized it was a very you
know unique story and I mean it was
obviously a huge deal for him to go to
this world cup I mean this is you know
his first woke up probably his last and
so I think that was one reason he he got
more on board is because we talked to
him about you know let's capture this
journey leading up to the world cup and
then he also was interested in
hearing what people had to say along the
way because the way he did his story was
so unique I mean you know he had to get
the quote unquote the professional
league he went from playing in front of
50 people to having a tryout right
before the season was starting with a
professional team and he was curious to
hear what you know what people had to
say like his teammates who who this
brand of American guy who just shows up
and next thing we know he's on the team
literally signed the next day and you
know his coaches along the way and
people that he live with in England
where he slept on an attic so I think
that was one thing he was interested in
because he hadn't really stopped to look
back so he liked that aspect and they
like the fact that the world cup was
approaching and that was a kind of kind
of what did it you said something that
was sparked my ears you said he didn't
come from the quote unquote system can
you define what that system is I mean in
in Europe the system is different in the
u.s. in in Europe the major countries of
Western European countries if you want
to play professional soccer let's take
you know David Beckham for for example
David Beckham when he was like seven
years old got signed by Manchester
United he goes he lives at the club he
studies for ten twenty percent of the
day and he plays football the other
eighty percent of the day soccer and she
does that all the way until he's 16 you
know it's I signed the contract and then
by 18 19 you either know you're going to
make it or or you're not and that's
really the system in Europe is it's you
know you you live it same with South
America same same without 42 actually
you have the talent and clubs will take
you in and they'll pay for you know pay
pay some some money and get you to do
what you need to do school wise but
you're really just playing in the u.s.
it's a bit different you are obviously
don't do that and most people at least
until the last few years go to college
they play college soccer and then they
sign a contract but they also play in
the US soccer the national team system
you know they usually start and under
whatever under 10
12 and then it gets more serious he
playing under-17 World Cups and under
1920 World Cups and you really you know
you get to know the u.s. style of
playing the coaches the players and JB
done Annette I mean he played soccer in
college he didn't get signed to a
professional team you didn't get drafted
and so at that time he's you know 21
years old without any quote unquote
soccer resume and he had no real you
know path there is no path for him to go
on there's usually it very clear to find
paths and for him he could have stopped
he could have gotten a job but he chose
to take whatever money could get
together borrowing it and using his
savings and probably asking his parents
for a little bit and took money in a
backpack and just jumped over Europe and
how long was it from the moment you
decided you were going to make the film
to actually rolling the cameras very
short probably eight weeks we found a
cameraman about a week before we were
going to start shooting maybe two weeks
before literally we went online on man
you got comic of a craigslist for
foreign film and we put it up and said
hey we want a cameraman here's you know
here's the film and I think we had about
250 people respond so we kind of
whittled it down and just were blessed
to find someone who we were you know we
weren't anybody's I mean we weren't
Hollywood we were in a production
company but we found someone that really
worked out well um and you know that was
that was it we went from there to all
over the world three continents all 50
days of shooting no Nick who made up
your filmmaking team and what did your
equipment consists of
funny because the cinematographer who's
actually at that point he was probably
three months out of college from
oncology just moved to LA and you know
he even in that time he he worked on
some some more you know high budget
films and and and projects and you know
he said look you usually have a lighting
few dividing guys sound guys maybe make
up our our team was three people and it
was a cinematographer and then ronca
myself and it's something needs to be
done with lighting or sound you know he
would tell us what to do and we kind of
started to get the terminology but we
had zero technical experience and we
relied on him and if you look at the
film it actually was shot in high def
and it actually looks like it's a decent
budget film I mean he's amazing with
lighting and really just capturing
things so we got really really lucky
because that was it we had a camera we
had some lighting equipment busted it
rented and yeah the mic and out of it so
with no experience the three of you you
make this film I mean looking back on it
do you sort of wish that a professional
director or filmmaker had kind of come
in and and done this all for you or are
you grateful for all of the I'm sure you
know times when you wanted to tear your
hair out and and things weren't going
right or as it sort of season do you
don't you're grateful for the experience
or do you wish someone else that kind of
come in and just taken the reins that's
a hard question because I I really at
this point can say that I'm very happy
with the film and the way it portrays a
story I mean it it is probably a story
that deserves well I mean it definitely
the story that deserves more I guess a
bigger budget more more of a team but
I'm very happy with what we did and I
think Jay is as well and it really
captures a story and there were probably
some advantages to and that
no we it would have it in the right
person because I think we got people in
the soccer world and and you know we're
going to England and and talking to
coaches or you know well very well known
professional coaches and the same thing
goes for in the US and the national team
coach but just because we're able to
talk soccer so to speak i think it was
able to bring out more from them and
maybe give them a bit more respect so i
don't know if i can really answer your
question but do you think that the final
product is pretty amazing Nick I like
the thoughts you shared there yes no I
thank you for that and it and I'm
wondering do you have any other insights
that you learned about yourself or about
life making this film yeah definitely
the film starts out with a quote the the
poorest man on earth is not one without
a cent it is one without a dream and for
me personally that that quote means so
much because um you know it symbolizes J
story of someone who did it have much
you know when it when it came to what a
typical soccer player or athlete or you
know woke up athlete a World Cup player
would have but he had a dream and then
he really did what it took and I think
the film the way it came out symbolizing
that because you know again we weren't
professional anything's we weren't film
guys I mean I like film and I dabbled in
it but I was not a professional but we
really had this goal and through hard
work and determination we made it happen
and I think that maybe I've learned that
is it's really the sky's the limit
onions if you know I would have gone and
told people what I was doing because I
really didn't tell too many people hey
I'm going out and making this film but
if I would have said hey guys I'm going
to spin the next two years and make a
film and it's going to be in theaters
behind by guys I mean people I work with
or you know people that just know me is
some some
lawyers some random you know some random
person on a filmmaker not a director and
I would tell people yeah and I'm that
you know direct this film and oh it's
going to get covered in Sports
Illustrated and Huffington Post in the
New York Post and you know we're going
to be on Sports Center people would
probably laughed or said no way you're
you know you're crazy or just ignored it
completely but I guess through this
process it's kind of secured my my
beliefs that things are possible i mean
really disguise on it because you have
gone this traditional route and you've
gone to law school and you've passed the
bar and now you're practicing so you
didn't tell too many people that i could
see how in that that professional realm
people would scoff so you kept it quiet
from co-workers and family yeah being
like my family knew about it and yeah
some of my friends did but it's funny
because I showed it to a few peaceful
and they say whoa that's actually a real
film like they didn't get it I mean
they're so you know I guess anyone can
make a selman and film things but I
don't I don't think it would have really
mattered i guess because i don't think
they could have understand i mean when
you see the film on the big screen its
helm and so when i've shown people i
think they've really been blown away
this is film courage we are on the line
with filmmaker nick lewis of rise and
shine the Jay DeMerit story I'm go to
Jay DeMerit story calm to find the
screening near you connect your campaign
is number three all time and money
raised on Kickstarter what was your
strategy regarding the campaign video
and why did you decide only use the
feature in the trailer we went out and
we made this film and there wasn't any
announcement like you know documentary
coming out about professional athlete it
wasn't in the trades or anything like
that I mean but when I say we were in
the wilderness we were literally in the
wilderness we we just went went went
filmed worked our day jobs just you know
head down like always always rushing
always some sort of barrier
you know not well barrier yet there were
always barriers but also deadlines and
things we had to do and then from there
we kind of set a deadline to try and get
something ready for Sunday so it was
crazy amount of work editing and you
know we had a hundred plus hours of
footage like we have shown it to anyone
we were just in the world and this
process we met a hub with a friend of a
friend who ended up creating this
trailer and it kind of accidentally went
on YouTube and got this amazing response
from people like the first you know what
do you mean it accident out here on
YouTube what do you mean it the guy who
made it we were he was like yeah you
know we should put it up and we we
talked and we were kind of like well I
don't know and I don't I don't know
exactly what happened in conversation
but we weren't clear it was going up and
the next thing we know it's like all
over the Internet at least in the soccer
world and you're like wow we didn't even
realize it was up you know we weren't
really expecting it to even be up yet um
so we went from being like in the
wilderness is and we didn't know if
anyone like it we didn't know if any one
watch it we just thought well we've done
something at the very least taken shows
grandkids his story but um from there it
was my attention was immediately on to
it and it was like documentary on Jay
DeMerit coming out so I guess that's why
we use it on a starter because we have
that you know it really propelled it
into something that was like a like a
realistic thing like at this point we
actually have something that can
realistically be shown and people will
wash it so you know we were actually
through that trailer we we ended up
putting a something that said for
distribution or funding call my cell
phone and on we got tons of calls and
then we also got a lot of people who
said hey you guys should check out this
Kickstarter this crowdfunding method and
we talked to Jay about it
and you know we talked to people we
talked to Hollywood people we public
investment people ultimately through
variety of things we figured that was
just the best way to go for us for
multiple reasons and now that's why we
put the trailer up I guess because it
really is something that we knew people
enjoyed and it worked and in speaking to
the quote-unquote Hollywood people at
what point did you realize to move on
that maybe some of those promises
weren't going to pan out and that
Kickstarter was the way to go I mean
where you may be jazz by the idea of
somebody coming in and writing a check
for it through this process here we've
learned and somewhat I could say that
you can use a lot of different areas of
life but if you want to get something
done you have to do it yourself and that
it just rings so true I mean for
everything you've done it's kind of been
the point that we can always go back to
but you know there's people get
interested especially in film and
there's a lot of talk but um either we
didn't feel it was right because it
wasn't this film has never been about
money for us I mean that's been the last
thing on our minds and let me tell you
the impounding hunting we personally
spent on her own now not ever knowing if
this thing would ever see the light of
day so that wasn't really something that
was was even you know weighing on her
mind except that we had this barrier
because what we had is we had a film but
the licensing rights to actually show it
around the world and you know in the US
was so expensive to show this this
footage really license it temporarily
for film festivals but you need to show
Premier League footage a World Cup
protégés starts to run in twenty
thousand dollars a minute and we had the
huge number that we were facing and and
that's when we really did you know we
wanted to find something to get it done
and we talked to people but it wasn't
nothing right ever happened for one
reason or another and we were also not
just going to wait around you know for
something because there's there's a big
like I guess with film and things like
this there's a lot of people get quote
unquote interested but actually get from
point A to point Z there's so much that
has to kind of get worked out along the
way and we really wanted to I'm just you
know not to rely on anything because
what happened is it falls out or it
doesn't work and then we're back to
square one and you know we had this
momentum going where we got the pot
going and the trailer out and people
continuously asked well how can I see it
so we move pretty fast and getting in on
Kickstarter and we set the highest goal
ever actually for a project and that was
because we wanted to make sure we had
enough to get it done simple apps we
didn't have to go and find more money or
you know delay the process so we set a
goal I think 250 thousand dollars and we
were I guess ready to entertain other
things if that didn't didn't happen but
we just went all out and did everything
we could to make it happen I'm sure to
your being an attorney and being
knowledgeable about contracts probably
helped in the process to speed up the
decision with Kickstarter may be hearing
some of these things where it might keep
other people in limbo for a while but
you probably saw from your own
experience if the paperwork's not there
then it's probably not legit yeah
exactly that and also there's just
something to say about too many cooks in
the kitchen I think where you know
everyone who gets involved want to have
their own vision and they want to change
things and sometimes they just want to
change things for the sake of them being
able to feel like they're playing more
of a part of it which I totally
understand and it's totally fine but I'm
you know we live this project at that
point for over a year and I think you
know along with Jay we felt like we
really could um could tell it the best
and do you love the fact that it was
something that he's always been a guy
who's really like um one of the fans and
by that i mean we asked him hey Jay do
you have any jerseys to give away for
this Kickstarter he said no I I give
them all after every game I always pops
onto the fan you know he'll he'll go out
and
a beer with fans and really easy just
you know that that guy is really really
he'll always go the extra mile to sign
an autograph or do things and you love
the fact that this could be something
that could be made possible by support
of fans and you know people who like
independent film and and obviously a
great story like his which really is a
it's more than a soccer story I think
it's a you know universal story of
achieving your goals and persevering and
it's something that it's grown and
people are really realizing the value of
it and I don't want to get too far and
tangent but I just think that especially
today with the films that you see come
about you know where these studios in
st. 30 or 40 or 50 million into making a
comic book support you know some just
huge action blockbuster I mean to have
these real true stories I mean people
are hungry fun yeah people relate to to
that quote unquote underdog as well and
they they really want to root for him
mm-hmm you don't think I can't help but
wonder you know I mean obviously the
licensing licensing rights to the film
you know caused you to set that mark at
215,000 very ambitious I'm wondering
what what would have happened if the
licensing fees came out to a million
dollars which would you still have
launched a crowdfunding campaign and do
you think you would have been able to
reach that goal I gotta lost it I've
enough already to go but yeah I mean
we're gonna do whatever it took to get
it done simple as that I don't think we
would have stopped I mean we invested
time and effort and just not only that
but we saw like throughout the process
of filming we just there are so many
layers to jay story that we didn't even
realize because you know we talked to
him and we read about it but the more we
talk to other people and Mike brought
things out the more we realize just how
unique and how special a story it is so
it was something that we you know I
don't think we would give it up let's
talk about right before you launched
campaign you know you find out about
Kickstarter people saying hey you know
you guys should take a look at this you
know then what did you do I mean how
much time before you know you were
hearing about Kickstarter until you
actually launched the campaign you know
so what did you do in that in-between
time we spent about two months and it
wasn't like we just spent two months
completely focusing on tips are like you
were talking to people about again about
investments I mean you had you know a
few quote-unquote bigger Hollywood names
ask around and get it you know get
interested but we also again felt like
we didn't want to put in in anyone
else's hands so we started exploring it
and the first few weeks just kind of
looking into it and you know figuring
out because it for people who don't know
about Kickstarter like me I'd know I did
the concepts are something you see
you're familiar with and that's
basically to all or nothing where you
know it takes a little while to graphs
and you have to raise all the money that
you say you have to meet your goal or
else you don't get any of it and we
didn't know you know there was there was
a right thing and then we hear week on
the more we learned and and the theory
behind Kickstarter which is essentially
that as people come on board and feel a
part of your project and get really
invested as well and want to make it
succeed so once you get closer to that
mark you have this momentum in this
variety of people that are out there
supporting your project helped push it
over so you kind of got familiar with
that and we figured out our numbers that
was another big thing we get a lot of
number crunching and then figuring out
the reward system where it's a you know
you're not donating for people that
don't understand Kickstarter and then
it's a concept that actually takes a
while for people to get but you're not
just donating money to the film they're
getting something back and what it is
you get rewards and we had to figure out
you know what would
good rewards what would make people want
to contribute to the project so we got
that squared away and then we kind of
wrote our story up Jay's story you know
just got that whole thing ready and then
made more groundwork with getting our
social media ready because without that
goal you don't want to just start at
zero i mean we try to really get the
momentum going i'm in the few weeks
before and then we I remember that night
we launched it we just spent like 20
hours straight getting it all done and
launched it and I was it is a 75 days
and a lot of roller costs a roller
coaster the whole time because you get
so involved in the process and you know
it's really uh especially when you start
to get your goal you see it going up and
then some days it'll stay flat and
salmon gosh I don't want to miss this
goal and you know I put all this time
into and all these people are invested
and they don't want to miss it but um I
guess kind of around the halfway point
we said you know no matter what happened
it's completely worthwhile because it's
gotten the word out and people really
invested and it's clear that there's a
you know I'm passionate amount of people
that want to see this film so we took
out that philosophy I guess but it's
still stressful near the end it was
extremely stressful we got quotes but we
still had you know thirty thousand
dollars to raise i think in the six
seven eight the fourth so it's kind of
like well are we going to do this if you
can kind of break down what you did in
those weeks leading up to launching the
campaign in terms of social media like
you know starting a twitter account
right and facebook but what did you
actually do to find interested followers
because you have a really passionate
group i mean just from reading some of
the stuff on your facebook fan page I
mean there's kids that are donating
their allowance money a lot of that came
out through the process I don't think we
had any idea of how many passionate
people that were but we're lucky because
the soccer on the toxic community is
passionate and and it's a lot of people
who really
care about the sport so that was really
what we did is we reached out to groups
we did some some radio shows because you
know people did know about jay obviously
and and some knew about his story and
some were interested in hearing more
about his story so we did that and we
kind of raised awareness a lot of stuff
with blogs as well and I think that you
know for other people listening this can
really serve for any film because every
film has an audience whether it's film
about a car you know dog or a comic book
and its really figuring out how to reach
those people so that was one thing we
did and started to communicate with some
of the organizations with some of the
supporters groups you know fan groups
and like I thought I mean there's you
know US soccer the National there's very
passionate fan support group and we
communicated with them and told him
about the project and created a list of
all these different organizations and
people to reach out to so now that was
it basically we did that we did facebook
twitter and kind of started getting the
word out and letting people know that it
was going to launch on this date and you
know to spread the word obviously
because we utilize social network and
mean one hundred percent that was that
was what did it for us it just allowing
everyone to get the word out to everyone
ought to be interested and that was that
was it and we started out pretty well I
think the first he did you know we
brought in like ten fifteen thousand
dollars and it was exciting that was
kind of allowed us to continue to work
at this planning pace any tips on
constructing an email to someone for
your pitch I mean do you have any do's
and don'ts as far as how to reach out to
people it's a tricky thing you know
because so much of email we just go okay
and we pass on it but what was some of
the things that you want to incorporate
into this pitch think that do doesn't
really explain what you're doing
obviously you know that for us it was
partially explaining that
what kickstarter is and what we're doing
and really letting people know who you
are I think that was important like
people got involved not just in a story
but in our story because they really
like to see that it was you know people
who really you know we're not
professional filmmakers and we it was
pretty obvious I mean we were just I
guess I don't how to say but we wrote we
were open to everyone like I think when
you get maybe a studio they probably do
it the exact opposite way worth like for
us you can have call my cell phone
anytime female we responded every single
person and it was you know no person was
too small and we wanted everyone to be
part of it I mean we you know we involve
people as much as we could and whether
it was asking for recommendation on what
we should do or you know people hey can
you get jaded tweet about me yeah no
problem I mean we did everything that we
could and we really made it a very
inclusive thing so I don't know if that
answered the question but regarding
emails I think just a lot another dude
is allowing people um letting people
know what they can do and not making the
50 things but hey if you are interested
in Jay story and trust you know if you
want to see the sport grown and you know
reached new levels here's what you can
do you can do XYZ and tell the coaches
in your town and you know invite people
to go to our Facebook stuff like that
and one of the folks you attracted to
the campaign Stuart Holden US soccer
player currently playing for the Bolton
Wanderers and he gave you guys had a
substantial pledge so I wanted to kind
of mention that but but as if rocco's
story and jay story aren't enough can
you tell us about Evan one dine and his
connection to this film yeah Evans are
men in the match as we say he's a just
an incredible incredible kid I think
that things like that are what has
gotten Jake
involved actually because you know he's
lived this but he had no idea that this
story would how the impact it did and
when he sees people like Evan out there
I mean it's really just brought it to
another level 4 J where you know I think
he's humbled and amaze and it's really
made him want to work and do whatever he
could to get it out because it's not
your traditional way to get a thumb up
and evan is a kid out in a Texas who Jay
Schuler play um he's 14 but he's got the
mind probably sharper than the most 30
year-old attorneys that I know most
four-year-old had a really really
awesome kid awesome writer so smart he's
gone through a lot with his own health
he's not had cancer and fought it and
then multiple surgeries in his chest
actually and I know you've gone through
a lot of pain but um it has never
stopped him and he's someone who's
really doesn't want the attention on him
but I mean he should have his own story
social he's just incredible what he's
done to inspire others and he loves the
project I mean he is so fired up that
something like this is happening where
um you know it's allowing other people
to achieve their dreams if that makes
sense p by getting Jace story out people
have really I think so like they've
accomplished a lot because we've had
people like Evan become so involved I
mean to raise funds where we have this
big goal you know he went door to door
and he set up his own three-on-three
soccer tournament and he ended up
raising well over fifteen hundred
dollars and by well over 1500 but the
amount of attention and people that he
brought out has been incredible he's
arranged for us to do you know
interviews where he said hey this
big-time sports guy wants to interview
you guys because he really just an
active sharp guys um you know /
and her a fourteen-year-old it just
blows me away Wow maybe that's your next
documentary right there yeah I mean it
he really is never about him he if he's
not doing this he's always doing
something else to help other people out
we wanted to get a few more questions in
about first off the theatrical deal did
you land that during the crowdfunding
campaign it was cool because we had been
um communicating we signed a
distribution deal for the theaters with
that company called the entertainment
and they're a smaller company but
they're awesome huge hearts and they're
really just been we've been blessed to
work with them because we worked hand in
hand the whole time and they reached out
during the campaign very early on and
say hey it's a cool project i want to
let you know who we are no this is what
we do and that meant a lot because at
that point it wasn't like okay we're
gonna you know reach our goal and get on
Sports Illustrated their stuff like that
they just they saw the project and they
liked it and then after the goal is met
we talked to him again and we talked a
few other people but we just felt like
it was the right thing mainly because of
the the just the the presence that they
had and we were able to communicate
really well it's been often we've worked
hand-in-hand I mean we have 0 ad budget
we've done one over 130 theaters now but
literally 0 ad budget and you've
utilized all of our social networking
and you know they've done an incredible
job of getting us into theaters and
we're just blown away by how big the
film was gotten and you know and again
in such it in a way that it happened is
incredible and it's been what barriers
but we've overcome each one and I think
a lot of that comes down to j story and
then just the passion mind you know the
people that have become involved and
we've had two thousand people contribute
but so many more people become involved
and where do you plan to be Thursday
November 3
I'm gonna be you know and Hollywood at
the arclight hollywood brain you oh yeah
yeah oh alright very cool it'll be
awesome well those of us in italia we
got to get out to the arclight and see
you then and see this boom yeah I just
encourage everyone is playing in at all
the arc lights in Los Angeles it's
limited release right now so the dates
are November bird in November 10th in LA
there's also some sunday shows sunday
matinees and again you know Jay DeMerit
story calm has all the info I just
encourage everyone to watch it because
it's I think it's a big victory for
independent film for more on nick lewis
and rise and shine the Jay DeMerit story
as he mentioned please visit Jay DeMerit
story calm where you can find times and
places of the premiere on November third
at jade and you can also find them at
Jay DeMerit story on twitter and
facebook com / the Jay DeMerit story
thanks again Nick for your time we
really appreciate it and was great
meeting you last Sunday at the filmmaker
form and we just really love your
enthusiasm thank you thank you guys so
much Nick I just wanted thank you enough
just phenomenal job and just love to
have you on the show and really wish we
could have just extended this another
you know we really do thank you Nick
yeah thank you all right guys hey Karen
and again thanks and you know I'm here
if you need anything I wish you the best
yeah we sure do we should thank Ronan as
we head out here use wavin at US bank
thank you for all you do for astronomy
groaning we're getting out of here
winnin until next Sunday have a great
week